andré gilles disait qu'on ne peut pas
faire de bonnes l'itération avec de bons
sentiments et bien can 84 nous prouve
qu'on peut tourner très bon cinéma avec
de bons sentiments par exemple le film
de bertrand tavernier présenté ce soir
un dimanche à la campagne et héros en
effet son toute une famille de
banlieusards de grande banlieue très
gentil
et est plaint justement de bons
sentiments il très propres sur eux c'est
pas très jolies filles
pourtant nous venons aux traditions avec
lmh sur prime film danois de lars
ailleurs on n'a jamais rien vu de plus
tadic sur un écran de festivals et
pourtant que c'est sur mon avis enfin
vous savez que les personnages de la
femme siddiq présenté hier soir sont à
la fois très frénétique et finges
érotique et à cause de ça ou malgré cela
film a déclenché beaucoup
d'applaudissements quand même quelques
protestations
il a surtout déclenché des larmes de
boudou slam sur les jours valérie
capelle qui
gilles à ce qui n'en mène pas large
regarder
manille
j'ai dix ans sur les photographes un bon
point mais des anges c'est vite dit s'il
a fui en tout cas nous fasse un ange
c'est qu'il fasse assez joliment
semblant moi je pense que le cinéma
c'est un tout petit peu plus
et un peu plus important que ce qu'on
avait l'habitude de consommer tous les
jours
alors je n'ai rien contre la
consommation de tous les jours mais
j'aimerais bien moins spectateurs de
venir au cinéma et du recevoir quelques
petits chocs
c'est maintenant aux chocs petit choc
d'émotion de beauté d'expression que je
trouve salutaire pour ma survie parce
que sinon est ce que vous croyez que
cette civilisation là qui nous entoure
ça vous rend tellement heureuse vous
insérez accompli votre destin de
complètement leurs feuilles de là dedans
il fait quoi
1 vous vous trouvez épanouie
complètement il n'y a pas de chômage
vous gagnez bien votre vie et vous êtes
nombreux à dire ça non non je ne le
pense pas alors est ce que le cinéma là
dedans doit-il simplement divertir pour
faire oublier
oui bien sûr parce que c'est c'est c'est
chouette de faire ça mais ce qu'il ne
doit pas aussi dire nous sommes avec
vous nous vous comprenons 1 et malgré
tout cela nous sommes pour tous un tout
la vie le sexe
l'érotisme les choses les choses de la
vie je ne suis pas le père mais moi mon
français n'est pas toujours reçu par
fait qu'il devrait l'être mais j'ai ce
sentiment extraordinaire de la vie du
cinéma et je leur trouve que rarement à
l'écran voilà
wen est arrivé voilà toi petite frappe
pour qu'ils travaillent crif à quel
avenir nous prépares tu
oh
lorsque des wagons de retard mais c'est
pas moi je suis pas encore totalement [ __ ]
encore que ça manquera pas de venir vous
connaissez une histoire qui ne soit pas
érotique vous offrons le petit chaperon
rouge sertic ou pas si vous êtes averti
que dans mon film il ya des scènes qui
peuvent ne pas être de l'ordre du
divertissement pur 1 qui peuvent vous
entraîner dans des régions et je
l'espère du fond de mon coeur de
réflexion d'attention de d'attention à
l'autre hui un j'en suis ravi moi je
pense que le cinéma c'est un tout petit
peu plus
et un peu plus important que ce qu'on
avait l'habitude de consommer tous les
jours
alors je n'ai rien contre la
consommation de tous les jours mais
j'aimerais bien moi spectateurs de venir
au cinéma et du recevoir quelques petits
chocs
c'est maintenant aux chocs petit choc
d'émotion de beauté d'expression que je
trouve salutaire pour ma survie et petit
sac comme celui ci sont peut être bon
pour la survie danger mais il semble
qu'il n'ait pas été bons dans sa
sélection à cannes
annoncé puis refusé que je crois que jay
douglas qui a toutes les raisons du
monde d'être furieux bape un furieux
mais déçu parce qu'effectivement cette
année c'est un énorme travail etc et que
ça aurait été très bien dans la en tant
qu'événement jeudi à dans la sélection
officielle du festival
c'est vrai que c'est beaucoup beaucoup
de travail et que c'est un an plus un
film difficile donc donc qui pourrait
être intéressant au sein d'une sélection
officielle
bon il se trouve que la la la la la
presse a parlé de 2,7 entre guillemets
injustice je veux dire après le fait que
le festival ait proposé une séance dans
à l'intérieur de perspectives du cinéma
donc je crois qu'il ya eu il ya une
chose qui s'est passé avec avec
l'organisation même du festival de
cannes qui a voulu quand même aidé le
film au maximum cette année quand même
très grande fête du cinéma est que cette
fête
elle ressemble en quelque sorte la vie
chez ma soeur on allait fait qu'on
mérite
et peut être que le cinéma ne mérite pas
une fête meilleur que que câble c'est à
dire que cette part de tout ce qu'il ya
autour reflète peut-être la vie
quotidienne du cinéma je ne sais pas en
tout cas quand on est exclu
en quelque sorte de cette fête ça fait
du chagrin tout simplement d'une façon
tout à fait simple et enfantine mais
c'est un mouvement peut-être d'orgueil
il faut punir leurs gagnants soir
enfin que toi
nous y tenir et zappa poétique mais
plutôt 107 ces dernières la plaira aux
producteurs et des mecs qui passent des
photos avec des filles à poil ou des
acteurs qui sont là tous balade
là vous êtes ici de dante dans trois
heures je serai avec un autre mec est le
festival de cannes si ça ça veut dire
ses couvertures de le média cd journaux
et des télévisions partout qui parle du
cinéma alors la seule façon de dédé le
cinéma c'est de parler du cinéma
il faut montrer 4000 personnes qui ont
envie d'aller voir un faible parce que
quand le film est projeté dans les
salles dans toute la france n'importe
quel film et qui a personne à l'entrée
du cinéma qui a trois tondus 4e les
dents dans la salle ça fait pas du bien
aussi les mains pour moi quelqu'un de 20
jours pour faire un ouvrage aussi
délicat cc relatant que la marque
combien de phase iib papattes relégables
c'est parfait il dispose et ce qui est
ici comme ils l'entendent et mon cher
petit gonzague je ne veux pas les
personnes tout ce que jean partie si je
l'achète ne crois pas pas comment
j'allais sur les choses du coeur il se
fait de l'argent c'est tout à fait
normal que je te fais ce que je prends
selon lui l'autre jour près de drew chez
des paysans j'ai acheté une très jolie
couronne de mariée avec son globe de
mariée voulant vendu vos débuts on sait
que ça pouvait servir à rien alors
j'étais obligé de leur proposer un prix
ridiculement bas autrement n'auraient
jamais parlé moi très des niveaux
d'entraînement drôle n'est pas en
normandie au bassin de fait mal quand tu
m'as au désespoir métro n'est pas encore
venu de france
sans faux pas pourquoi mais c'est comme
ça et maintenant un gros plan sur un
nouveau sourire celui de sabine azéma
comme etienne 2 1 dimanche à la campagne
je voulais tourner un film avec rennais
c'était un film dans lequel j'avais un
rôle très de deux jeunes filles
provincial très douce très 6 me
très
introverti et
ces derniers m'ont proposé de jouer le
contraire absolument le contraire il fit
mondaine parisienne cocker et puis
évidemment c'est je n'avais jamais
tourné dans un film d'époque
oui
et
oh
j'ai demandé moi mon chef opérateur une
lumière une photographie avec une énorme
profondeur de chance à l'aspect type
d'événement est et dans les couleurs on
sait surtout inspiré ses premières
photographies couleur des frères lumière
des premiers autochromes n'est plus en
ligne aile mars par ailleurs danois a
lui aussi travaillé sur la couleur son
film element of prime est entièrement
tourné dans des tons de jaune que pia
avec des flashs le fluo en vous le
montrera des mains il vaut le détour
voici une scène de suicide rituel grands
poneys buan sensible
enfin mon premier des dix jours ce
village antillais à elisabeth bourgine
qui a pour nous jouer à la starlette
cannoise de traditions mais c'est une
vraie comédienne souvenez-vous d'elle
dans le social
j'ai une plus de race humaine je suis
ravi parce que c'est en anglais alors
j'ai l'impression que c'est
mais en tout sans renier parce que ça va
penser aux états unis
en taxant trop cher
attention depuis tout jeune folle enfin
je joue une seule robe et une pelle
gentil en fait en argot et un concert
avec lambert wilson